I feel like sometimes guys say things to
look out for us but we don't always like
think of it that way you know because
we're like well why can't I do what you
know
absolutely
and the men in our lives I've heard you
talk a lot about your dad and your
brother what I have learned with men
they're not going to say anything if
they don't care a lot of times we think
oh they're telling me don't go here
don't do this and we're thinking you
can't tell me what to do but if men
really don't care they don't say
anything they will walk right past it
and say not my problem not my family so
when you have a man who's trying to tell
you something it's because he cares wow
I never thought about it like that